let's talk first of all you know super
bowl's on a lot of people's minds yeah
we've been talking about it a lot on the
show uh you guys at startup live are
doing a super bowl
half time yes it's sure it's a weekend
update
halftime spectacular and it's and it's
going to be live
now is there any chance that you're
going to do your liza minnelli
impression
because she does an amazing liza minelli
that's horrible that's her long laugh is
that yeah
it kind of gets stuck like in her throat
right
so you're not she's busy trying to
breathe right
right of course alan a good friend of
license
and she's good yeah i don't do it with
laser did you realize you did a duet
yeah
[Laughter]
you both did it to get some ice cream
yeah kind of
yeah now i heard i don't know if this is
true but i heard that you're obsessed
with steve harvey and i don't know what
that means like you're
you're obsessed are you stalking him
steve harvey the comedian
what is it that you're obsessed with
about stephen i have no idea i
i think he is so amazing looking
first of all whenever i see him i i
don't know what it is but it
it fills me with an immense sense of joy
like it's um just when you see steve
harvey it's like it's like his hairline
is perfect
and he's got that like an amazing
mustache
and he just looks like a plastic black
man doll
right we have i think we have we have a
picture here of steve harvey
yeah i just always there he is yeah okay
i see what you're saying that makes me
crazy
you know what you're right i was feeling
a little down because it's so cold out
and everything
i saw that picture put it up again and i
felt really good again you know
filled me with joy
you know there would be no world war if
our planes just went around the world
dropping
leaflets of that steve harvey photo war
as we know it would end because people
would be like i hate those americans
steve harvey it was really it would
bring the world to a to a place of peace
and harmony and understanding yeah um
i like to end that like batman and
understanding uh
now you um on star not live you've been
having a good time you've been
successful
you've uh you've had a lot of successful
characters it's all going well for you
yeah but there seems to be a pattern it
seems like they've pigeonholed
you a little bit in a specific way yeah
i'm i'm usually the girl that they need
someone to be half naked i say i'll do
it
right and uh i i've sort of been
thinking about you know
this is my third season on the show so
i've been thinking about okay what do i
usually do it's like well i'm usually
half naked
um in an enormous wig i'm usually doing
some sort of dance and i'm usually
making out with people i've even noticed
that you're always the one that's making
out
on the show yeah they know that old
rudolph will do it i know
there's someone there with a cigar
that's like get rudolph get rudolph
on the horn rudolph we'll do it it's
true i i have no shame
and i and i will do it you've done a lot
we actually found a uh
we we just a little tribute to some of
the fine work you've done on tonight
live
[Music]
i'm just gonna go home from work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but now i'm feeling nothing
i thought that clip was longer yeah
all right we're going to take a little
break cool yeah i hope you're going to
be okay